Making drugs illegal does nothing to stop people from using them.
Our paralysis to see things differently
is also based on an entirely false narrative about drug use.
We have been led to believe that drug users
are irresponsible people who just want to get high,
and then through their own personal failings
spiral down into a life of crime and poverty,
losing their jobs, their families and, ultimately, their lives.
In reality, most drug users have a story,
whether it's childhood trauma, sexual abuse, mental illness
or a personal tragedy.
The drugs are used to numb the pain.
We must understand that as we approach people with so much trauma.
At its core, our drug policies are really a social justice issue.
While the media may focus on overdose deaths like Prince and Michael Jackson,
the majority of the suffering
happens to people who are living on the margins,
the poor and the dispossessed.
They don't vote; they are often alone.
They are society's disposable people.
Even within health care, drug use is highly stigmatized.
People using drugs avoid the health care system.
They know that once engaged in clinical care
or admitted to hospital, they will be treated poorly.
And their supply line, be it heroin, cocaine or crystal meth
will be interrupted.
On top of that, they will be asked a barrage of questions
that only serve to expose their losses and shame.
"What drugs do you use?"
"How long have you been living on the street?"
"Where are your children?"
"When were you last in jail?"
Essentially: "Why the hell don't you stop using drugs?"
In fact, our entire medical approach to drug use is upside down.
For some reason,
we have decided that abstinence is the best way to treat this.
If you're lucky enough, you may get into a detox program.
If you live in a community with Suboxone or methadone,
you may get on a substitution program.
Hardly ever would we offer people what they desperately need to survive:
a safe prescription for opioids.
Starting with abstinence is like asking a new diabetic to quit sugar
or a severe asthmatic to start running marathons
or a depressed person to just be happy.
For any other medical condition,
we would never start with the most extreme option.
What makes us think that strategy
would work for something as complex as addiction?
While unintentional overdoses are not new,
the scale of the current crisis is unprecedented.
The Center for Disease Control estimated
that 64,000 Americans died of a drug overdose in 2016,
far exceeding car crashes or homicides.
Drug-related mortality is now the leading cause of death
among men and women between 20 and 50 years old in North America
Think about that.
How did we get to this point, and why now?
There is a kind of perfect storm around opioids.
Drugs like Oxycontin, Percocet and Dilaudid
have been liberally distributed for decades for all kinds of pain.
It is estimated that two million Americans are daily opioid users,
and over 60 million people
received at least one prescription for opioids last year.
This massive dump of prescription drugs into communities
has provided a steady source for people wanting to self-medicate.
In response to this prescription epidemic,
people have been cut off, and this has greatly reduced the street supply
The unintended but predictable consequence
is an overdose epidemic.
Many people who were reliant on a steady supply of prescription drugs
turned to heroin.
And now the illegal drug market has tragically switched
to synthetic drugs, mainly fentanyl.
These new drugs are cheap, potent and extremely hard to dose.
People are literally being poisoned.
Can you imagine if this was any other kind of poisoning epidemic?
What if thousands of people started dying
from poisoned meat or baby formula or coffee?
We would be treating this as a true emergency.
We would immediately be supplying safer alternatives.
There would be changes in legislation,
and we would be supporting the victims and their families.
But for the drug overdose epidemic,
we have done none of that.
We continue to demonize the drugs and the people who use them
and blindly pour even more resources into law enforcement.
So where should we go from here?
First, we should fully embrace, fund and scale up
harm reduction programs across North America.
I know that in places like Vancouver,
harm reduction has been a lifeline to care and treatment.
I know that the number of overdose deaths
would be far higher without harm reduction.
And I personally know hundreds of people who are alive today
because of harm reduction.
But harm reduction is just the start.
If we truly want to make an impact on this drug crisis,
we need to have a serious conversation about prohibition
and criminal punishment.
We need to recognize that drug use is first and foremost a public health issue
and turn to comprehensive social and health solutions.
We already have a model for how this can work.
In 2001, Portugal was having its own drug crisis.
Lots of people using drugs, high crime rates
and an overdose epidemic.
They defied global conventions and decriminalized all drug possession.
Money that was spent on drug enforcement
was redirected to health and rehabilitation programs.
The results are in.
Overall drug use is down dramatically.
Overdoses are uncommon.
Many more people are in treatment.
And people have been given their lives back.
We have come so far down the road of prohibition, punishment and prejudice
that we have become indifferent to the suffering
that we have inflicted on the most vulnerable people in our society.
This year even more people will get caught up
in the illegal drug trade.
Thousands of children will learn that their mother or father
has been sent to jail for using drugs.
And far too many parents will be notified
that their son or daughter has died of a drug overdose.
It doesn't have to be this way.
Thank you.
(Applause)